des bassins totalement vide une image
peu commune de cette piscine
habituellement très fréquenté par les
habitants des clayes sous bois
pendant les vacances les enfants ne
pourront en profiter la piscine s'offre
son rafraîchissement annuel ya
obligation de vidanger complètement les
autres bassins d'une piscine au moins
une fois par an et en en profite puisque
c'est un équipement qui ouvert le plus
possible tout au long de l'année pour
effectuer quelques travaux d'entretien
ce soit de peinture dans l'emplacement
d'éclairage de luminaires de choses
comme ça
entretien des bassins contrôler
nettoyage des filtres à diatomées qui
traitent l'eau mais aussi peinture dans
le hall d'accueil
quinze personnes sont mobilisées pour
ces travaux autant de réaménagement
indispensable pour cette structure des
années 70 c'est une tâche extrêmement
importante les filtres a dit à peu mais
c'est d'y accéder par là où passent
chaque litre de piscine ou de bassins
tout ce qui touche à la sécurité de
l'hygiène dans une piscine qui est
extrêmement cadré extrêmement surveillée
puisque deux fois par jour on analyse
l'eau pour vérifier les taux de
chloramines à et les pollutions
éventuelles de l'eau donc il faut que
les installations techniques puissent
fonctionner tous les jours coût total
cinquante mille euros pour la
maintenance et l'entretien
après deux semaines de remise en beauté
la piscine rouvrira ses portes le 5 mars